selon un sondage kantar pour le
quotidien la croix 67% des personnes
interrogées jugent que les journalistes
ne sont pas indépendants des pressions
des partis politiques et du pouvoir je
pense que les médias nous disent qu'on a
envie d'entendre et ne disent pas
forcément tous mais c'est quand même une
bonne façon de connaître l'actualité de
savoir ce qui se passe dans le monde à
cause des meilleurs c'est le bordel dans
le sud est y stigmatise un peu trop je
trouve ils sont passés dans la réalité
dans le vrai
juste le potage l'impression alors
qu'avant il était choqué c'était un peu
plus dans la réalité internet a
considérablement changer des habitudes
des français 35% d'entre eux recherchent
l'information sur internet et les
réseaux sociaux un changement au
comportement qui a poussé la population
à s'informer autrement je crois qu'il
faut davantage d'éducation à l'image de
l'éducation aux médias pour qu'on ne
soit pas prisonnier de forme de
propagande qui sont complètement
délétère
et ça s'est installée pas fait tout ça
n'est pas fait suffisamment leurs avants
les médias c'était simple et la presse
écrite c'était la radio c'était la
télévision et s'était fait par des
journalistes aujourd'hui on a des médias
sans filtre sans médiation et même si
les journalistes essayent de s'infiltrer
sur les réseaux sociaux pour décoder
l'information pour faire leur travail en
fait ça ne marche pas parce que c'est
ses troupes instantanée ses troupes et
normes etc pour christian delporte la
seule solution pour retrouver la
confiance des français doit passer par
le retour aux fondamentaux du
journalisme
le journalisme c'est d'abord un
journalisme d'enquêté et l' enquête ça
passe par des protocoles ça passe par la
vérification le recoupement
d'informations
et
ça passe aussi par le fait qu'on ne
lâche ne voit pas la chose à faire on
doit continuer à travailler dans ce sens
ça ne doit pas être ponctuel ce qui
surprend parfois c'est pour ça qu'on
parle d' emballement médiatique à propos
d' enquête c'est qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de ses emplettes et bien le
journaliste doit enquêter en permanence
c'est son travail des fondamentaux que
les élèves découvriront tout au long de
la semaine de la presse et des médias
qui se déroule du 20 au 25 mars